c'est un son de liberté laissez-moi aller
n'importe où
mr.  police je vous chérie non seulement utilisez une arme à feu pour
tenir une place ou menacer quelqu'un ou
Robin ou un pistolet avec eux ou lui faire peur
mais non non chéri euh de toute façon c'est gratuit un
petit cadeau de bienvenue à la maison bonjour mesdames
personne ne m'a appelé pendant trois jours je  je suis une
légende un mythe un conte glorieux d'être au
début de génération en génération de
toute façon papa elle se moque de moi
été en prison 12 ans j'ai
beaucoup manqué ma fille qui grandit
[Musique]
je dois voir encore je pense que je  je ne peux pas faire ça moi
Dom visant la façon dont je dis juste ce que je dis
arrête de dire ce que tu
dis je prendrai ce que je veux dire dans
n'importe quel état je veux le redire
je ne suis pas tes dents  j'ai mal aux dents
t'ai coupé l'oreille je t'arracherai l'oeil
avec mon gros orteil en
passant ma douce lumière elle est en colère contre
toi depuis des années Hut n'importe qui a le
droit d'être en colère cette vie c'est moi j'ai de la
colère  les problèmes meurent juste est-ce que je veux
rattraper le temps perdu c'est pourquoi je suis ici mais
il se lève je vois une amélioration
tu es vieux je suis de la vieille école
[Musique]
à mes yeux,
mon petit-fils s'appelle Jawara kid signifie
épris de paix Je suis boum
Tom's English run lucky son of a [ __ ]
[Musique]
toi